from screen jumping studio in the heart
of Los Angeles this is screen junkies
moving fight now your host Andy signor
hello movie fighters did you know it's
the 20th anniversary a face-off that's
right face-off
so we thought what better time to do at
all special movie fights that's right we
are doing a cage match beautiful that's
right guys it's an all Nicolas Cage
themed movie site so we're going with
what's the best what's what performance
describes the essence of Nicolas Cage
what's the actual best performance
what would mo what's the best one liner
and what move you'll be most improved by
replacing the here both the hero and the
villain with Nicolas Cage in a dual role
also what Nicolas Cage character would
win a cage match in a bare-knuckle fight
so much fun stuff you're going to stay
tuned and I'm so happy to reveal our
fighters today look who's here oh yeah
we got John Flickinger host of movie vs.
movie here I'm Plus that as well as the
flick pic on YouTube welcome John back
good to be here man this is a great
episode I'm excited I'm scared at the
same time but it's Nicolas Cage so I
can't wait to talk about it I can't wait
to hear you guys talked about it next up
she made her debut on the debut
deathmatch made such an impression she's
back already you can see Rin screen
Huggies news with Charlie kerfeld many
thanks very much I I decided to go for
high from raising her zone' tonight
looks I can go Cameron so if I wanted to
roll it miss me you got a pani on your
head going for cadavers yeah good I love
it
finally he's a comedian Ana Schmo and
we're helping them trying across the 300
thousand subscriber barrier just feel
like we this is taking way too long what
is wrong with you and you do come on
I've been back in too long is that aside
and then go subscribe to schmoes now I
met Mariela it's dumb thank you Andy
chemical super freak Ashley but I still
need a gun YouTube algorithm man it's
just messing everything I'm worried were
this close for this look you boys let's
do I've take them over the edge if we
get to 300 - Mouse
let's get some rows there hey we did
that by the way thank you so rather
build in I mean who is the next to you
ladies and gentlemen oh my god here
killer here I'm here the [ __ ] Nichol
okay my voice is not impersonated I'm
the real deal Wow Majid can I hear that
Miller
levena here Wow what is this an immense
honor
Wow how we been I've been amazing I'm
dangerously high off dinosaur bone dust
sort of a whole whole shitload of it
before a puzzle Wow all right well I
look how maybe then that'd be great if
you could help us fat check the show add
an old fat check and if you can help us
tell us about the performances or
anything you were thinking I would
really I mean I mean I'm not sure guys
this dinosaur dump is a fact-checker
Andy but it's the real Nicolas Cage so
you gotta be no better than him yeah
we're beyond facts mate honor to have
you mr. Nicolas Cage in honor next to
you Dan Merle yo I mean this is what
your next Nicolas Cage magic I said
amazing like I said he was not here when
we started the show he's appeared and
I'm here House of dinosaur bone dust I
burst through the couch living now from
the edges I'm in a lot of debt yeah hey
are you on the screen junkies Wi-Fi or
Nicolas Cage is an actual Wi-Fi router
and he's a hotspot yeah we had it
installed after face off yeah well guys
let's start the show real quick I wonder
mindset teaser on a teaser setting a
reminder because next Tuesday this
Tuesday coming up is there 200 honest
trailer and you're going to want to
watch it first thing check it out make
sure you set your Suri's or whatever it
is Sam sorry Siri are you necessary very
serial X's whatever Tom all tennis or
10:00 a.m. Pacific Standard Time to the
200 honest trailer and while you're
saying reminders don't forget flick bait
is back Friday 4 p.m. Pacific time same
time we had fun last week dan didn't we
we did we had a blast
do you like the honest trailer career we
made the idiots of ourselves and talked
to the news and add some some quick bass
nonsense it was fun we'll be back this
tomorrow if you're watching on plus and
if you're already on YouTube there's two
episode you can go check out so go check
them out guys last announcement I got to
say this I'm so happy now
why isn't then put the belt back up
what's going on where's that fans vote
well Dan Merle do you even know that we
are in my outfit I don't know who the
winners I'd listen Erica not the
receivers a recycler okay next week's
fight will be the fan Choice vote for
the last spot to take you on
so finals yes you guys at home are
voting I'm happy to announce that next
week if you tune back in you will be
seeing these three people fight and no
particular order based on the voting is
to because there was a clear winner but
there were three winners the winner of
the fan choice poll is it a drumroll we
don't have that but later Candra coin
coins back in the running
yes mr. Mike Carlson oh my god this
Botanica time rate in a commercials been
Mike Carlton the great an insurance
commercial him all the time in La Push
Lee finally somehow eat in there the
outlaw John Roca not not have a chance
again the fans won them
he's there John Roca coy and Mike
Carlson will be taking next week chance
at the belt the winner of that show will
go up against Matt and our own GTE in
the booth and the winner of that show
will take on dan in a manoa mana
one-on-one fight the fight for the belt
so you guys are not going to miss that's
coming off so just so I get this right
now John has been given two free chances
for the film yeah hey look he rides his
horse over here from the valley right a
tough track for an equine well
apparently you're in there we go we'll
see if he take Dan out of those three
who do you think will win
ooh I mean I think that Mike Carlson has
the experience with the game we've got
the humor element I think that coy has
the speed and I think that John Roca
will be there doing by his own desire
like who find out he's a piece that you
know had a caregiver mo home I think
he'll do it although well tune in next
week to find out what happens in the
meanwhile let's get this cage match
started like that
[Music]
plants achondroplastic carmine
withdrawals baby doll okay let's run Wow
back Harry Lee for anything that amazing
montage that was beautiful thank you
Harry how great was that awesome awesome
he was here to my soul I love it Harry
you're the best thank you for doing that
I wish I got me ready for this match a
cage match it begins
round 1 what performance best defines
the essence of Nicolas Cage now this
could be a semantic thing but it's not
this is technically best Nicolas Cage
movie that's what we're asking here
what movie really defines the essence of
Nicolas Cage
Johnny are first okay just to clarify
this is the best Nicolas Cage movie not
the most over-the-top performance this
is best defines the essence of Nicolas
Cage we're not getting lost in semantics
F summary what do we think of when we
think Nicholas Cage okay what movie do
we want to do is you can change your
answer right now no I'm not sure I'm
sure
okay I'm going to go with the best movie
that defines Nicolas Cage just to make
sure one more time
this was the one I've just maybe nerdery
males like there's an email guns the
number ones I say yes yes yes yes okay
so this one no we're doing this one I
can tell you your arguments because yeah
great choice yeah both of them work
either way but okay I'm going to send to
your CompuServe again
there's also best performance which is
next okay alright as men performance
coming up but this is what's the
performance find the essence of Nic Cage
SS Nicolas Cage twitching smoking crack
these are the things that define Nicolas
Cage and the movie Bad Lieutenant
porthole of New Orleans is the movie
that most defines Nicolas Cage even the
director himself let Nick Cage go off
the rails he said you can do whatever
you want there's no script that's going
to hold you down do what you want
Nikolas cage and what did he do
there's 10 minutes of screen time
dedicated to him looking at an iguana
phenomenal he think that was exhibit
smokes crack watches the guy breakdance
on the floor
gets a gets a bj as the the girls
boyfriend looks on and he's just the
most corrupt cop you've ever seen on
screen and not only that this still has
substance it's not just five minutes of
funny Nicolas Cage scenes where they're
going to take the clips and put them on
YouTube there is substance in this movie
and a story and a character that you buy
into and Nicolas Cage was the only guy
who could pull some of the things off
that happened in this movie and also
there's one scene which in my opinion is
one of the best scenes ever put all the
way home you brought brought clip right
each of you have a clip to help convey
your moment this is one of many scenes
but yes let's watch the clip you owe me
15 thousand okay 25 percent though on
guys
that means you give up right that's one
way of looking at it the other is to get
to keep 75 percent not go to prison for
the rest of your life Wow and in the
words of Nic Cage himself that is his
lucky crack pipe there's also a scene
beyond that there's a scene in this
movie where Nicolas Cage takes an old
lady's oxygen tube and squeezes it until
he gets the answers that he wants I
bought into it and you know what I
didn't think of him as a villain when he
did that I understood his reasoning its
Nicolas Cage she made me believe in him
I've done all right I've done that good
start a great clip Charlie which which
what are you thinking I'd like to start
with a clip with mimei okay I like to
start with Nicolas Cage or vampires kiss
this is the clip eventually somebody
missed something what could be easier
it's all alphabetical you just put it in
the right but according to alphabetical
order fix it you're a b c d e f g h i j
k l m n o p o king
all you have to do
hey good you know your alphabet I never
saw any good Wow
so you want the primordial ooze from
whence Nick Cage as we know it that was
spawned from it is vampires kiss he is
left to his own devices through most of
the film there's okay those out there
who've never seen vampires kissed this
is what the semblance of a plot that
exists Nicolas Cage as a lit agent Peter
lo believes he has been bit by a vampire
and is slowly becoming a vampire that's
it that's it he's just going off the
rails slowly but surely
into madness and that's the only thing
we have going for it we don't have a
plot we just have his performance it's
Nic Cage doing the cage to the nth
degree Nic Cage we have a scene where he
believes that he should have vampire
teeth at some point he doesn't he buys
plastic vampire teeth puts it in his
mouth
tries to bite people goes around New
York going I'm a vampire
I'm a vampire it's him left to his own
devices in such a wonderful way that he
was able to create his expressionistic
performance that created all the
performances since then it is actually
one of his favorite performances never
did and he ate a cockroach you know
excited about being with off-the-wall
characters that he committed and ate a
cockroach he and this is the movie that
spawn means that you don't say it's him
up on a table screaming at women saying
that they haven't found things correctly
tormenting alva tormenting of Flash data
Jennifer Beals it is a performance that
is such a tour de force in nut job that
no film stands next to it
all right you know your alphabet Marc
Andy Nicolas Cage is such an American
treasure I'm surprised he didn't try to
steal himself in one of the national
treasure movies you know to get the true
essence of Nic Cage get to look beyond
just quick cartoony over-the-topness
although vampire's kiss are about
lieutenant have to look at the fact that
this guy is an Academy Award
level actor and I'm taking a performance
it encapsulates all the greatest it is
cases over-the-top craziness his acting
chops his action ability and that would
be the Sorcerer's Apprentice roll the
clip JT I have been searching a very
long time magically here you are
that ring on your finger means something
means you're going to be a very
important source no he's not anybody we
trust around a child but we let this kid
be babysat by Nic Cage because he's got
an earnest you got a touching quality
about him that allows us to still
believe in the cage after all of these
years yet he gets to be a sorcerer and
catch crazy spells and do all sorts of
magic so you get your crazy era Nicolas
Cage you also good action movie Nicolas
Cage because he has to battle demons and
protect this young wizard you also get
that dramatic ability that we saw
holding a statue once upon a time
Nicolas Cage is a trifecta of greatness
in the Sorcerer's Apprentice is a great
encapsulation of all those eras of mr.
cage trifecta was a trifecta of great
now great ok I get that line down
alright guys fight it out I just met you
but how dare bring out all the Nic Cage
movies you could have gone Wickerman
because we've done raising Arizona you
could have gone bringing out the dead
and you show sources apprentice where
he's basically cashing in a paycheck for
the mouse it is a soulless dead of the
iron performance he is sleeping through
this performance the priority we
mentioned the vampires kiss is why
Nicolas Cage I don't want is I go Darren
Nicolas Cage and I don't want red box
there Nicolas Cage The Sorcerer's
Apprentice gutted or decayed theatrical
release and it actually made money as
the box office has opposed the Bad
Lieutenant which is still sitting in a
bargain bin DVD some more and no one's
ever heard of vampires kiss because no
director was raining and then on that
movie if you just let Nicolas Cage fly
to the moon he's going to do it you need
a story to keep him grounded in order to
have action go from one scene to the
next this is sorry to have left but this
specific question was the best most Nic
Cage in performing as the essence of
stop it and every area listen listen
Nicolas Cage is a beautiful butterfly
and over to let him fly you need to put
him in a movie that's not pg-13 likes or
Sri Lanka's which was an abomination
against mankind and speaking of making
money it did not make money it was a
box-office bomb and crowd did not do
well but it made more money than Bad
Lieutenant or vampires together because
people fly to go see the essence of
Nicolas Cage and nobody even knew they
were making a sequel to Bad Lieutenant
and nobody knew what the vampires kiss
well I've written clear aidid Bad
Lieutenant is a superior film and
actually a substance it's a story that
people remember and it's also a movie
that Linda started in the first place
I'm really absolutely hope you haven't
earned it on the guide John oh it's a
movie that lends itself to allow Nic
Cage do what he does best in a rated-r
nc-17 environment where you smoke crack
and almost kill old women that's what
I've got to say when it comes in a cage
he's freaking out he's twitching he's a
corrupt cop Nicolas Cage was with one of
the worst hair pieces he's ever worn and
that says nothing about my age that does
something it looks like a wet mop that
someone glued to his head that is
Sorcerer's Apprentice is bland it's
tiresome no one remembers one line Nic
Cage gives them an entire film not one I
can't remember anything that stands out
to me we're not talking about the
quality of the movie though we're
talking about the inhabitants of Nicolas
are you guys a couple as far as the
right decisions you go and source
McCracken is a movie that people
actually remember you can't have the
essence of Nicolas Cage be defined by
film that nobody saw or nobody remembers
I imagine people don't remember he was
doing Sorcerer's Apprentice in Evalia we
got all the greatness of Nic Cage Itamar
what was the great moments and source of
credit agreements and sources
apprentices towards the end when he
sacrifices himself in order to save his
younger wizard apprentice to allow him
to fly so there's actual acting in there
that's not mailing it in he gets to get
in a costume Nicolas Cage embracing
being in a different world in a
different place a different time
snorting damn-near dinosaur does he gets
to be nuts but he also gets to be a real
character as opposed to caricatures Andy
which is these two people making fun of
Nicolas Cage I'm here to make fun
Nicolas Cage I'm here to celebrate the
greatness of
rated actor who occasionally can be a
nut job I appreciate your enthusiasm for
but no amount of you raising your voice
is making that performance any more
energetic or interesting energizing a
good performance that can be understood
now when you talk about vampires kiss
you're seeing all of the flavors of why
we love in a cage and exactly why he's
perfect in movies like that he elevates
that movie because we know he's going to
do something crazy we know he's going to
do something crazy because if vampires
can because we've seen him go to the nth
degree we seen him go
this expression is bizarre gonzo
performance and that's what made him
Nick Cage we know him to be this way
because of vampires kiss because he is
part of his mind we change the accents
missiles no one has ever made that
action before no one will since no one
could have done vampire's kiss except
for Nicolas Cage because it is pure heat
but now caricatures what do you guys do
probably when it comes to vampires kiss
the best thing about that film is you
can take six minutes of Nicolas Cage and
you can put it on a funny rail reel on
YouTube and that's what you have from
that movie no one remembers anything in
between and he has a few funny scenes
and Sorcerer's Apprentice he essentially
plays a coked-out version of Merlin the
wizard we have with JB Rochelle and no
one wants to watch it I don't honestly
as far as essence goes I don't remember
one key moment or one scene with Nicolas
Cage in that film that's I'm going I'm
going to remember six seconds after the
movie with Bad Lieutenant this is a
story where he has depth he goes up and
down he's an antihero in a lot of ways
but also he's a coked out crooked cop
there's a there's a different dynamic
there and as far as essence goes the
crazy outlandish things that he does in
my movie compared to your movie is it
makes sense to the script and the story
it goes along with what's happening in
your movie he's doing the bizarre [ __ ]
just for the sake of doing bizarre [ __ ]
and it's funny but as far as essence
goes with quality or substance it
doesn't find anything else in the movie
but the essence of the movie is his
descent into madness so how do you show
The Descendants Amanda's you show him
doing things that no man could possibly
do unless they were going crazy and it's
already talked about having a highlight
reel the entire movie is him there's
very few things that do not have them so
it could have possibly a highlight reel
is the entirety of the movie badly
Tennant is Werner Herzog's vision as
well as Nic Cage vision it is both of
their craziness come
together in this amazing fantastic
hilarious way but it's still Nick Cage
restraint what I want Nick Cage I want
him to be out there I want him to be
bizarre and it's not a characterization
it's not a it's not a cartoon it is
essential to him as a Nick Cage
performance if you want to go essence of
Nick Cage that's how you do it
Andi I'm sensing a paradox because while
I argue and I get louder and louder and
that somehow shouldn't count as much yet
the only time he was the essence of
Nicholas Cage the count is when he gets
louder and louder and crazier this man
is a Lamborghini and the Lamborghini is
more than just about going fast it's
about the way you can break quickly you
can handle the turret you can go on a
city road you can go to long country
Drive Nicolas Cage shows he can do
everything with range and the Sorcerer's
Apprentice as opposed to be in a film
the bad dope which is a better movie
than Sorcerer's Apprentice vampires kids
maybe a better movie than Sorcerer's
Apprentice
but Nicolas Cage's performance is more
layered in that and he gets to showcase
more of his cage isn't than just one
phase in a club named mcphobe from
Sorcerer's Apprentice
I am your sorcerer I don't know that
movie and then he says we all go next
Engle tonight let's go to Dan and the
cage man himself yeah Nicholas what do
you think I may call you Nicola Nick you
can call me whatever you want okay sir
Mick sir Nick what do you any thoughts
on these performances are I definitely
agree with vampires kiss all right well
yes yeah we got the respect that's Nic
Cage is opinion I know I acted a
sorcerer as a participant but I've never
actually seen it I don't remember
anything very dangerously hot like that
guy could die any second damn it is he a
good sort a legend alleged Nic Cage
thank you go no matter which one of
these wins the essence of the cage is
that the movies a flop because vampires
kiss was made for two million dollars
gross 725,000 Vangelis n it was made for
25 million grossed 1.7 million and
sources Apprentice was made for 150
million euro 63 billion so which is
domestic ah that's the best exist two
million dollars for iguanas alone
Charlie is right that he did eat a
cockroach for vampires kiss he also
snorted baby powder stood for cocaine
and Bad Lieutenant
and the people are Twitter soulmate
everyone has a different answer Tim
Buckner says best Nic Cage movies
Raising Arizona which doubles as a great
Coen Brothers movie
Anthony Hernandez says it's got to be
castor Troy that one's just bonkers and
you Shia Alex Brill says none of these
three choices should win or even be top
three
hashtag Conair hashtag drive angry
hashtag ghost writer they're gonna see
the crude screwed yes I didn't see that
one papa I think I'm going to go ahead I
also have the viewer poll which is
pretty close right now all right well
look I think Marc you gave a very good
argument but I do think that gosh you
just you picked a weird movie that even
you had trouble remembering course up I
haven't seen it but we're close now with
a movie I'm serious you really showed
the passion so I valiant effort but it
did come down between Charlie and John
on that one yeah I just I think I got a
little bit more - Charlie was describing
what the essence of what we want with
caged more hits to cinematics what we
want them over over-the-top all that
stuff we want them out there you said
it's a highlight reel but it is sort of
what we want so I think Charlie got that
back to you even though was close John a
guy give it to Charlie for the first
point
vampires kiss does to find the essence
of Nicholas Cage I don't believe that
movie I hope you get people to watch the
movie if nothing else
oh you're straight alright enough I
didn't think he was going full alphabet
what do you want by the end of the fan
poll voted for The Sorcerer's Apprentice
right the only one they've probably seen
ya newest one yeah don't look for the
new ones vocalizing yeah batting the
argument actual treasurer might have
been a better choice would that not
that's not the essence of cage that's
action-movie cage there's a printer come
to control it even it's probably a
yeah okay I know a national treasure but
we don't have one can do this one
instead okay but anyway that was a good
point guys all right this one comes in
from Scott Lang question to hear it man
what ant-man yeah man Sally amen this
one comes in seriously now what is Nick
Cage is best performance because we did
you know he is over the top do you
called over the top Nick sir no it's a
operatic okay I never go over the top
I'm always in control of everything I do
I love that we no disrespect you sir I
love your work
even though operatic is the president
but let's go what's the best performance
period he has won an Oscar ease and a
lot of really great roles so let's here
we got Charlie our first what is the
best Nicolas Cage performance so it's me
the best sort of Nic Cage performance
does still have and add like elements of
caging it but it's still an acting
performance it's still something that
you look at it and like yes I believe
there's an actor behind all of the coke
I so I chose something that I really
truly believe wasn't just a throwing him
an Oscar I think truly leaving Las Vegas
his fourth of L Ben Sanderson is the
best he's ever given cinema he took two
weeks go went on a bender had his friend
film him just to find out what kind of
drunk he was how he slurs how he could
get into this character of it again we
got we'll go from literary agent to a
screenwriter who has lost everything his
wife's divorce him he's lost his kid he
is ready to die he goes out to the
desert he goes to Vegas with the
intention to drink his life away and he
is persistent at that but you would
think would be a bleak movie and it's
not it's funny it's charming you'd
understand why elisabeth shue hooker
with a heart of gold would go for this
sort of person even though he's at the
edge of his of his razor edge his room
and his room
you understand why she would see him as
her service dangerous or out her descent
into sadness and lateness because there
is this charm there is this behind his
eyes you can see that there is promise
and he his performances a nuanced
portrayal of hitting rock bottom
and having it consume you body and soul
it's a performance of physicality of
humor of depth and it is devastating and
that's why I truly believe it's the best
work you've ever done on-screen mark you
know any whether you're talking about
acting or athletics or anything else
sometimes the greatest performance is
the one you're not expecting when you
say oh this guy's there they're easy
passes prime he's never going to win
another championship if you're talking
about Tim Duncan a few years ago or
you're talking about some guy popping a
viagra and throwing a football through a
rusty tire one more time Nicolas Cage
did that in Joe Joe's a movie that came
out of nowhere that you I go is just
another movie he's doing for the
paycheck in the long list of directed
DVD movies and it comes out and do that
well financially but critics said you
know what this is the guy that we
thought we were getting when we saw
movies like leaving Las Vegas this guy
is finally banking on the promise and I
saw that movie at the time myself and a
lot of other critics agree this could be
the start of the Nicolas Cage
Renaissance in the same with Matthew
McConaughey was able to revitalize his
career starting with the movie that not
a lot of people saw the Lincoln Lawyer
now the reason why Joe is such a great
performance by Nicolas Cage is because
he's able to take his ability to go
crazy but he doesn't do it in his
outlandish operatic performances it's
all in the eyes there's not a lot of big
movements by Cage it's all with his
facial twitches the way that he's
looking at this character who he takes
in ty Sheeran and who's being abused by
his father he gives him a job his job in
life is to poison trees to clear way for
more construction now what's that access
as a metaphor for Joe's own life and
it's a heartbreaking end to the movie
because like a lot of Nicolas Cage's
greatest roles he ends up having to
sacrifice his own self whether it's
physically in death or whether it's
metaphorically and giving up in order to
save somebody else it's one of the most
nuanced performances as you'll see in
the ox and it's a great / underrated
movie all right
flick pick your all right I'm gonna go
with matchstick men this is a film that
allows Nicolas Cage to tug to really
focus his attributes and what he does
best and also it puts it into a story
where you care about what's happening he
has a daughter in this film it's a
father-daughter movie it's heartwarming
he's also a con man and he's twitchy
there's several scenes where you get
freak out Nicolas Cage moment but then
the movie focuses and settles down and
you get this heartwarming story about at
the core of it is a father and daughter
and you care about the dynamic of what's
happening in there and along the way
it's also it's also drinking by Ridley
Scott phenomenal director the visuals
the script of this movie spot-on and
also like my movie there's a lot of
rewatch ability here it's not a one
watch movie you want to go back and
revisit it you always find new things
about this film and the little nuances
nuances about Nicolas Cage's performance
in this movie like I said he doesn't
just freak out he's not just typical Nic
Cage and he's not trying to do something
that he doesn't quite fit into he's
doing everything he's great at but he's
focusing on a quality character and you
care about the entire relationship that
he has with his daughter in the film
Dickman max man leaving Las Vegas Joe
let's fight it out guys somatic men I I
don't feel like he's performance work
for me this sort of he's test rat he has
OCD and he's very like twitchy and
flicky and it always told it kinda fun I
saw I saw I saw the acting I saw the
line the acting I saw him put on a
performance instead of living in the
character whereas with Joe I did not in
leaving Las Vegas I did not was leaving
Las Vegas he embodied I didn't you made
me see it i okay
good with leaving Las Vegas at the
height of what I think Nic Cage can do
he can give you so they always say dying
is easy comedy is hard and with meeting
Las Vegas he is legitimately funny both
in how he delivers lines in his
physicality but he's also devastating
it's a sad movie if it's the embodiment
of you see we're alcoholics go where the
possibilities of their their their loss
their rock bottom and with mastic men I
just I love the script
I love ready scouts direction I love Sam
Rockwell I love all the other
performances but for Nick Cage he felt
false these are two really good movies
and I think I think my problem is max
Bergman is that Sam Rockwell is better
than Nicolas Cage in that movie I don't
think Nicolas Cage is the best
performance in his own film and with
leaving Las Vegas at Sur there's a
reason why Nic Cage won the Oscar for
that movie but he's acting against
Elizabeth Shue and they are such a great
chemistry paper I think a lot of that is
what Elizabeth Shue is bringing to the
table as far as Joe Nick kay Jesse's
acting with ty Sheridan and he is
helping a mushroom along but most of the
greatest without Joe and I performance
in their die think
criminy overlooked when it came award
season is that Nicolas Cage's acne
against his great acting partner ever
himself he is just wrestling with his
own demons and you get to see that even
more so than in leaving Las Vegas where
this is a guy who's trying to slowly
poison so with alcohol here you get two
more visually have a representation just
in his eyes as to what this man is going
through and the best reason why it's
Nicolas Cage's most prized performance
is because you can watch it through the
prism of this character Joe you can also
look at it through Nicolas Cage
reflecting on his own career and where
that might have gone if you didn't get
so horrific Lee in debt buying dinosaurs
that he could have been this different
path it's almost like you're seeing Joe
go through his own life you're also
seeing Nicolas Cage replay these great
moments of his career like the rock and
Conair and seeing where that went into
knowing in the Wickerman and seeing you
know what I still have this ability to
act and I'm going to do it I don't know
that's the last time we get great
academy award level Nicolas Cage but if
it is he went out on top with Jim I'm
gonna agree with Ellis and say Elizabeth
Shue did prop up Nicolas Cage in leaving
Las Vegas exactly they kept falling ever
as far as Nicolas Cage playing a drunk
is that really a stretch he's played an
alcoholic a cokehead he's played
everything in every movie and they just
so happened to write a script that
catered to Nicolas Cage a broken clock
is Right twice a day and that's what we
even Las Vegas got lucky got lucky with
a script in the role I wouldn't say it's
his best role by any means Elizabeth
Shue outshine him in that movie
I cared more about her than I did
Nicolas Cage's I read in adventures in
babysitting it's why I loved as far as
Jo goes it does belong in the five
dollar DVD than at Walmart
I understand earlier he was given a
subtle performance he really was he's
playing a safe performance but at the
same time I don't think it was his best
performance by any means he didn't go
out on a limb he played a very safe
secure performance and it you kind of he
almost took what he used to be in and
made it into a former shadow of himself
and Jo and it's very bland it's not a
very great movie and as far as my movie
goes matchstick men there's a there's a
heart there with my movie you get the
best Nicolas Cage and Sam Rockwell Sam
Rockwell hard that movie started taking
it up and you started thinking it was
Cage on a downward spiral really Scott
on a downward spiral Jo he's already
bottomed
and he's giving one last shot at glory
with matchstick men it's a movie that
came out and people this is going to be
good and it wasn't it was a
disappointment and as far as a five
dollar DVD bin every movie we talked
about on this show is going to be
available for five dollars somewhere
everything okay it was critically
acclaimed people liked it and also Sam
Rockwell yeah a great supporting
character but Nicolas Cage outshines him
there's multiple scenes where he goes to
the pharmacy freaks out and then you go
back to another scene with him and his
daughter you're like oh I care about
what's happening in this movie he's a
con man he's a selfish con man but at
the same time by the end of the movie he
has a character arc where he completely
changes how he was in the beginning of
the movie he's a different person by the
end of the movie than he was in the
beginning of the movie I don't know
anyone could have played that part it
didn't maybe one person who could have
played that part don't keep that kind of
play at that part usually could have
played that part I think Johnny wrong
1308 it doesn't feel like a nonsense
like this is the cages height a foot and
that's our artillery scene from Nicolas
Cage so many times it was like it's like
the family man thing it's like oh now
he's completely changed and everybody's
better the greatness about Joe is that
this guy realizes in this an audience
time we go along for this emotional
heartache that he realizes he can change
who he is to a certain extent but he can
never get out of his own skin fully and
that's a tragedy absolutely let's go do
final thoughts go ahead charlie
I think the mistake is believing that a
restrained performance even though this
is Nic Cage restraining is quite an
ordeal is a good performance and with
Joe I do feel it is too subtle it's it's
not as it's not the Nic Cage we want to
see I think with I think that maybe in
Las Vegas is his performance of a
lifetime because it gives you all the
elements you want to see from in a cage
movie you do get the outlandish list but
its towards a purpose it's towards the
plot of the movie we also get these
quiet moments you see the devastation
behind his eyes the thought of his wife
leaving him the thought of this woman
taking him in and feel like he can never
give it back to her because he's on his
way towards death and knowing she's an
angel trying to help him out and knowing
that he cannot do anything for her so
the shoe is wonderful there's a reason
she didn't win the award and he did he
carries a movie it is horrifyingly
depressing but also hilarious and
wonderful and it's why he won the Oscar
and why he should win this fight I think
the reason why Nicolas Cage is good in
leaving Las Vegas is a lot of it has to
do
elisabeth shue being able to partner up
with them as opposed to Joe where Joe is
not just a performance based on subtlety
there's moments in that movie of sheer
violence Joe is a violent man with a
violent background and just because
they're not showing us every action
scene that he's been involved in in his
life there's a bar scene that is
frightening in that movie because you
see the quick rise of anger he has and
the audience doesn't need it spelled out
form that this is another instance where
this guy's getting into trouble because
he's too violent we get to see a glimpse
of it and that's enough because we get
to see the rest of a very nuanced subtle
performance one that people did not know
Nicholas Cage still had in and that's
the movie I point to Nicolas Cage ever
goes on a career research and it's going
to be because he was able to do Joe and
people really hope the movie didn't do
well it's available in most bargain bin
when you watch that performance you say
that guy still has greatness in him John
when people don't watch a good Nicolas
Cage movie I don't know anyone who wants
to watch leaving Las Vegas for a great
Nicolas Cage performance it's a good
script but as far as Nicolas Cage's
performance goes yeah it's forgettable
Joe is one of those movies where you
have Nicolas Cage but anyone could have
played Joe in that film or anyone
could've played the character of Joe in
that film Nicolas Cage didn't bring
anything that he was great at into that
film and he just shoehorned it in there
and that's why it went straight to DVD
he did it for another paycheck it was
the latest trend in this DVD that had a
theatrical release in one theater in
Boise Idaho and as far as matchstick
then goes you know and one of the best
had the best director out of all three
Ridley Scott in my opinion and also once
again it has layers my character is a
con man who plays multiple characters
throughout this entire movie and he has
the biggest story arc has wrapped an
entire film by the end of the movie he
truly is a different person he learned a
lesson and it was a lesson that was a
tough one at that to learn but there's a
heartfelt relationship there and it kind
of leaves you with a little you almost
feel like a little bit of lump in your
throat by the end of the movie but the
message you take away you figure out
that stickman if I may run I think
watching a character learn a lesson is
not as intriguing always as watching a
character know there's a lesson to be
learned and he's just not able to make
himself to it
more the second I will only hear the
first is I'm from Boise Idaho from the
joke estable
all right mr. cage and Dan Moreau let's
hear for you guys I I have to go with
the crews first one this was one of my
bigger paychecks recently all I had to
do was say ugh into the microphone
several times you remember making Joe
kind of yeah
yes I was in the woods I think all right
that's that what was we're involved yeah
all right edit beard I had a beard which
I still have remember the two-week
bender you did for me in Las Vegas
research oh yeah I'd love to see those
videos carolers are floating around the
you know I think a video I mean when he
brought it in sorry so sorry Sam we got
Joe was directed by David Gordon Green
who might over pineapple Express and
he's founded down it was released in 48
theaters and it came in 31st place the
week that it opens if it's the second
weekend of Captain America the Winter
Soldier so who's that's not a different
more people shoot seems you know you can
get all three movies for under $10 on
Amazon I checked yeah and a lot of
people as you can imagine on twitter
jamaica defense says the correct answers
adaptation but i would argue for lord of
war it's and Butler says it's moonstruck
hams the juicer says no take that a
patient Wow
Ryan dealing cases something really
unexpected amazing with Big Daddy and
kick-ass and Nola Dean also agrees the
kick ass is a runner for this round
because Big Daddy is is pretty much the
best part of that film no mentions of
the Croods no one mentioned the crude
but you ready expert he was like my
that's my prediction yeah go to the
crude actor you don't remember that one
guy wasn't even more recent I said ugh
more times in that way double Doug all
right this one is rough it did come down
to me between leaving Las Vegas and Joe
I think John got huh you just got a
little hung up on the I mean you did
called leaving Las Vegas kind of mad I
don't I don't agree I don't know I
didn't hear any degrees are Boise
go and you didn't get it focus on the
directory they said yours was the only
one was layered but I would disagree I
think they're all closed they all did a
very good argument of why they were
layered so it came out of Charlie and
mark I've seen Lila's a while ago I
haven't seen Joe so what really this is
really based on the arguments and I hurt
you you are the first to bring up the
Sam Rockwell defense against his which
was a good point
you brought in the research so that was
also helpful but yet I didn't you said
the argument against mark was Joe was
too subtle where yours is all the
elements but I don't know we're not
talking cage now we're talking best
performance and the fact that you were
also sort of able to say Elisabeth Shue
really helps him a lot do that
performance a little unfair because it's
still a performance he's giving but I
didn't have that much to go with I had I
was sold on wanting to watch Joe and
your defense of it so I got to give Joe
the point mark gets it Chris Parker
America's favorite babysitter
I love of injuries in babysitting in
that winter pole was the left of this
change they run away 53% voting for
leaving Las Vegas Joe and matchstick men
currently tied so it was very close
Carly that was good you're both your
time with mark there we go question 3
let's go silly now ok let's go back to
being silly
what movie would be most improved by
replacing the hero and the villain with
Nicholas Cage in a dual role a lot of
patient mark where you what are you
picking up you're going big and you're
going to movie they've got a lot of
people talking about feelings
taking one time taking the other side
that's right DC fans we are going to
remake Batman V Superman we're going to
make it better courtesy of Nicholas Cage
who it's not going to be playing
Superman
although he was Superman Superman we
took very briefly Superman lives that
movie didn't happen this movie should
have because he is going to be a great
Bruce Wayne / Batman and he's also going
to be a great Lex Luthor because Lex
Luthor gives him the chance
first of all with his hair plugs he can
either go with the hair Lex Luthor like
Jesse Eisenberg dead he can just shave
it and that's a great entry into his
later work I love Bruce Willis where
it's like [ __ ] I'm running out of hair I
better shave it for a roll so the kids
think I'm just doing the
on purpose and then when we go to him
playing Batman / Bruce Wayne who better
to play a tortured soul who wants to
fight crime but also is going through so
many personal demons than Nicolas Cage
you see it in every performance he gives
he's capable of great action like we've
seen in the rock and Conair he's also
capable of great personal hurt in his
performances like all the movies we just
talked about particularly leaving Las
Vegas and Josie take that broken soul
and you put him in a Batman V Superman
ow he's got to go against Superman and
it's just icing on the cake that he's
going against the former role that he
used to have so it could be like a
Michael Keaton in Birdman situation
we're essentially looking against the
role that he used to have and he's going
to get it he's going to top it he's
going to beat Lex Luthor he's going to
beat Superman because it's Batman V
Superman that would Nicolas Cage me and
Batman he's definitely getting the W
Henry Cavill still Superman every Camel
can be super okay John I'm going to go
with go with the matrix I want to see
Nicolas Cage as neo and mr. Smith
yes could you just close your eyes for a
moment and imagine this mr. Anderson
like could you imagine that and could
you imagine magneto going whoa I could
imagine both things wait let's hear it
again mr. cage mr. Anderson whoa
all right there is nobody great you
throw Orpheus in there you have a movie
you can truly see Nicolas Cage
taking on either performance in these
movies he would add more charisma than
then either character actually did you
had a way to get Hugo Weaving Kenema
Keanu Reeves yes thank you for both
those days and they both kind of had
flat performances in those movies
Nicolas Cage would spice it up you'd add
more of a character to both of them he'd
had more substance to both of them I'd
love to see it go down and could you
just imagine the scene where Nicholas
Cage you know has a fight with himself
with bulletyme action sequences his face
is on both of these characters that
would be the best thing that ever
happened to set a thousand Smith cages
as well in the sequel you do Andy don't
get ahead of yourself right on the first
minute here transitory I can only take
yeah my pick is going to be Nick Cage
entirely what are you doing so similar
thought only in the Bukowski's but I
thought when I looked this question what
movie would be improved now to move that
is already great or a movie that can't
be improved
I chose Jupiter ascending because I
believe that Nicolas Cage not the Mila
Kunis character although he would look
fetching in that 10 South I think he
could do the Channing Tatum character of
being a fake puppy there to protect Mila
Kunis with princess and also when we
look at Eddie Redmayne giving the
whisper voice the very landlord's he was
essentially doing Anna Cage impression
already wouldn't it be better if it was
actually Nic Cage during the role a lot
of people do love Jupiter ascending I
feel like it was a movie that could have
been better that their elements that
really could have pushed it into being a
well-done sci-fi movie and frankly
McCade has not been in enough sci-fi
movies what I discovered for his IMDB
this could have been the one he could
have taken both characters you could
have loved him for being the caring
compete reott on the road trips through
space with neo Kunis and the absolutely
gonzo whisper monster that is Eddie
Redmayne character Hubertus ending would
have been so much better with his
inclusion
alright guys find out I think the reason
why Batman V Superman is the best move
for him is because it's the one that's
most polarizing to fans is they just
didn't get what they want so let's have
some fun with this as opposed to Jupiter
ascending which I think people would
rather just bury than ever bring up
again we need a good Batman Andy we need
somebody's unexpected a lot like when
Michael Keaton was cast as Batman people
start as always that's the guy the guy
who's coming from a comedic background
but was able to bring a tortured
darkness to it Nicolas Cage can do the
same thing and then with Lex Luthor
that's when he gets to have all the fun
that's when it gets to be the crazy the
essence of Nic Cage they were talking
about because he can be as crazy tech
magnate can go off the rails talking
about all this great technology wants to
do what he wants to do how he how he's
going to create doomsday all of these
elements have Nicolas Cage written all
over them and if I can borrow mr. cage
one more time if you can quote the the
quintessential line the one thing I
hated most about Batman V Superman is
when he's the Martha thing happens but I
would have bought it if it was Nicolas
Cage saying why did you say that name
why did you say that name Martha is also
my mother's name I think you'll buy it
furious if he was Batman curtain it cage
as Batman maybe he's got to pull off a
Lex Luthor but stealing me Sokka thought
they would see it as a joke if there was
an occasion a meme he can be any
character and make it really hilarious
but can he make the movie better he can
make Batman vs Superman better by being
Batman he would be ridiculous and the
matrix is already fantastic it is a
smoke bear role played by Keanu Reeves
because he should be kind of a cipher
character he is this person where he is
exploring his chosen as' and things sort
of happened to him and he's very zen and
Buddhist and thingit's her ago passive
Nic Cage can't possibly do that Nic Cage
has the influence that he's an
influencer he's an attack dog and was
mrs. Smith similarly he's got to be
entering mr. Smith and although they
would be funny to see within in the
sequel the actual first movie I think
his character his personality would
overpower it I think it would be a
phenomenal performance I think he also
has the weird surfer voice that he's had
since the 1980s for some random reason
and I think would work both for neo and
mr. Anderson also mark as far as your
role goes if you would have said him as
Superman I would've bought that I can
see that as Batman know we had a
phenomenal Batman Ben Affleck was great
and Batman you might not be playing
Batman anymore you need to be in that
video more than what you would've said
doomsday Otis said okay I'm going to
pre-order my tickets right now okay but
you know as for Nicholas Cage as
Superman that works as far as Nicolas
Cage as Batman there's no way you put
that cowl on there he's still Nicolas
Cage easy knees Corky's twitchy's all
over the place Bruce Wayne is Superman
is more of a OneNote character anybody
could be that's why Henry Cavill can
just be pretty much a wet blanket and
still play super super but Nicolas chase
so much going on behind the eyes and as
far stupider spending goes
just because you picked by far the
crappiest movie out of these creators
doesn't mean you're allowed to say oh I
don't want to touch the gold in this it
is Batman V Superman because Jupiter
ascending is the moment it's going to
prove the Nicolas Cage when he's in a
crappy production he getting today
over-the-top performance that does not
get attention when Nicolas Cage is in a
quality production that's going to get
eyeballs on it he gives an a effort he's
not going to give an a effort in
something like Jupiter ascending or
something that wasn't unknown property a
time like the matrix if you
give Nikolas came to roll he can sink
his teeth into and commit he grew up
loving comic books Andy he grew up
worshiping these characters he's been
waiting for this role his whole life as
opposed to Jupiter ascending which is
just another paycheck for him or the
matrix which is another reason to go
crazy and his whole life yelling for
Batman his whole life he physically been
waiting for Superman so that is your
choice to do this have that over
Superman for him tonight jump it's a
more complex character nice this
arithmetic Kate is getting more drawn
apart Jupiter ascending is concerned
it's something where Nicholas Cage cans
biggest he goes into because it doesn't
have the baggage of a property it
doesn't have anything that he can't make
better he can create this character from
scratch and make it in the cage we want
to see Batman is not the right role from
not how he is now I'm probably not how
he is then and with the matrix I eat
first of all go surfer voice he's
totally channeling over there and not in
his beautiful Elvis all the time and I
don't that would have been you for me
it's too he has too much character to be
Mia Keanu is a passive Buddhist face of
grape this temerity I don't know he was
a he was a piece of drywall and with a
little bit of paint on and we were
walking on a rocky is first Jupiter
ascending goes you can recast anyone you
want at movie it still goes to the movie
itself and the script of the movie was
awful it was boring it didn't matter who
was playing what Eddie Redmayne had a
Nicholas Cage performance and it was
still awful to watch he was like boy
what a fella since me and Ellis as far
as Nic Cage me a huge comic book fan and
loving the movies that doesn't do
anything look at the movies a
ghostwriter that didn't turn out too
well either so I put no faith and
Nicolas Cage playing another comic book
character especially one of the most
iconic ones one of the biggest brooding
badasses of all kind Batman if you give
him a redemptive movie like Batman V
Superman this is the movie he's been
waiting for to give him a career
resurgence it's not going to be cheaper
sending because people are going to see
Nicolas Cage
maybe they oh it's just another crappy
movie you're going to see the matrix
they're going to be like there's no way
he can pull off that and character that
young or that complex but when you put
on the age of Batman this is a different
Batman than we're used to seeing on
screen this is an older Batman this is a
Batman that has been through stuff he is
scarred emotionally he's jaded
this is the role that Nicolas Cage may
not have been read for 20 years ago but
Annie at this point in time in 2017
Nicolas Cage is the right guy to take on
being an anthem of Batman and also Lex
Luthor one of the craziest over-the-top
villains but still has a menacing threat
to it
this is everything Nicolas Cage has been
waiting for his entire life as opposed
to just getting a paycheck imagine final
thoughts enjoy John final thoughts you
make a good point with everything you
said except for the Batman part that's
where you lose your argument he could
play Lex Luthor he could play doomsday
he could even play Superman but when it
comes to Batman he could not play Batman
as far as your movie Jupiter ascending
it was a bad move it doesn't matter who
you cast in each role it's still going
to be a bad movie it was my movie The
Matrix
it's a very complex film and it almost
in a logical way you could make it work
to where Nicholas Cage is playing both
roles he could be fighting against
himself in this movie and the
complexities of that and my story would
actually make sense to see him as both
characters Charlie final thoughts um
that would change the entire point of
the matrix if he looked like the mr.
Smith character where if you take
Jupiter ascending he could absolutely be
this space Prince out out in the
wilderness as well as this other
character and it would still make sense
the plot would still make sense
and he would elevate it because he is
ridiculous and I think he belongs in a
space opera that will hold him and this
is a movie that has the bones to hold an
occasion whereas veteran Superman we're
not living in a vacuum if people were to
hear that hey we've cast Nic Cage as
Batman I think they'd be serious current
Batman current Nic Cage if you were put
into that role people would write a
furious when Ben Affleck would cast
anyone Michael Keaton would count they
get mad about stuff they get one over my
final voters is yours yours ours you do
have a fantastic radio voice services
thank you this is Nicolas Cage big
Batman pbx you're Nicolas Cage in
traffic Nick how's it looking on the
planet out there traffic is packed huh
it's backed up
it's Batman up Charlie anything else
like that oh yeah the source before I
was interrupted hi
he would not be make a good Batman even
in his youngest days his his heart has
always been Superman and I think he
doesn't he'll he'd be a laughingstock I
think he would make too much fun out of
the character that some people prefer
them to take him seriously
alright Dan and mr. cage any man here
I'm really upset that none of you
brought with the fact that I was almost
Superman I didn't get around in for a
meal okay
anyway it's the radio because it's
hateful memories I do like all three of
your ideas you got which one would you
do so I go back would you rather be in
the matrix jeepers anymore back those
demos I'm good to it I do like all three
of your ideas we got Wicker Man V
weather man we have moonstruck ascending
and we have of course the cage trick but
I have to go with my own personal
favorite the live-action remake the
frozen coming out 2019
oh you're playing Elsa and I playing
Elsa and Anna if I get a word rest mocap
or noses live-action live-action I gotta
wear two different dresses I'm excited
for that plan any actual faction like
that don't have access people online
Colin mer says The Wizard of Oz with
Nicolas Cage's Dorothy and the Wicked
Witch to was Mac Paul says I'm going
with Street Fighter I want the Kate to
play both guile and invite Minh oh we
had numbers as cage home alone
protecting himself from student cages
like a little CGI neck a little CGI cage
and the papal throne make Kansas yeah I
think the viewers Wiseman yeah yeah and
then tab at test suite says a Nick Nick
Cage has played Batman and kick-ass he
played Big Daddy so we play the kind of
the Adam West interpretation in a way of
Batman not closer closer so big Oprah a
lot of good thoughts actually I think I
could see him it's older Batman they
could probably pull that off
jeepers sending that is a good choice it
is the least probably the worst film but
John had a really good knock I think I
just like well Eddie Redmayne gave a
cage performance unwatchable it's not
really with a high mark for you John and
then at the end strangely enough we you
also sort of point out Ghost Rider which
it could turn into which would actually
be worse than Batman V Superman's mouth
yeah it would be
and then when you said you could find
themselves somehow I could then I
thought about like the coding could have
made him look like me Oh to fight it
like it could they change their site so
weird League I'm gonna go with the
matrix based on arguments John gets the
point I see that movie I want to try
yourself all right
this made in the viewer poll is print
it's somewhat close but 43% voted for
Batman V Superman 31% look for the
matrix 26 percent voting with your
percentage no crude dozen to the poll
maybe they'll put it in the next poll
you were in the Croods man Ted Cruz -
all right round four this comes from
Josh 72 Richter we'd like to know what's
the best Nicolas Cage one-liner now key
here this is the best line read of one
line what's his best line read does not
so know it is a little bit about the
line itself but it's more about his
reading of said crazy line or nice fun
dramatic whatever line and I believe we
do have the lines you can cue up when
you're ready John your first okay let's
start off with my line let's see that go
down I said
the bunny back in the box
alright that is a line that says more
than just put the bunny back in the box
that is a convict going home to see his
ladies and that bunny represents freedom
and the only man who could deliver such
a line to that magnitude is Nicolas Cage
it's threatening it's terrifying another
actor in the history existence of
Hollywood anywhere in film could ever
say a line like that and make me believe
it and make chills go down my body into
my spinal cord and the fear that I that
resonates into my body after he says
that I buy into it that is the best
threat I've ever heard in a movie in my
entire life
all right charlie all right so I am the
only lady within earshot but I do feel
like this will also affect your loin so
I think we're all together on this
this too this is the clip would you like
anything else once we're airborne
you know I can either be your hours oh
god oh god you're thinking you know I
need a Pete Rouse we thought my god the
Allman Brothers album so not only has he
ruined peaches for everyone here he is
ruin oral sex which is a very very hard
to do it is such a including Lee creepy
way of saying that thing oral of say is
trying to seduce this woman and he sells
it in such a great disgusting way
they're kind of like oh yeah this could
get word I could be internet Oh
maybe depending where this flight goes
and he knows she goes with him but why I
love this line reading the most is it
had to be so good it had to be so
demonically creepy that when John
Travolta says it later you realize or
his family realizes oh no this has been
caged this whole time it had to knock it
out of the park and it does it is that
sort of creepy light reading bet it goes
through time of Nic Cage when you think
about not only his best one-liners but
also what he says the best and most
creepy it is great
all right mark your turn nati shows a
line that is the essence of everything
that is Nicolas Cage both in body mind
spirit and it works so well in the film
wild at heart JT show me some more snake
skin jacket flicks baby don't ever tell
you that this your jacket over consume a
lot look at reality and my belief and
personal freedom
nothing says individuality and personal
freedom like Nicolas Cage because that
guy shows up to a movie said he does
whatever the hell he wants he has that
metaphorical jacket on at all times
whether he's doing an action flick or a
drama or some sort of red box lock set
Nicolas Cage is always true to his heart
however nutty that may be and that line
that is repeated throughout the movie in
a much cleaner way than the force
MacGuffin of face up is why that is the
best encapsulation of who Nicolas Cage's
as an actor as a personality and also a
character in wild at heart all right
guys I'm going to say I could eat a
peach for hours is a phenomenal line
it's at my pickup line and it works
sometimes until they call the police
I think it's a great line I don't think
it's an iconic line in a line of people
remember from say soft but it may be
kind of all amazing lines here but it's
not the best line by any means you know
as far as Ellis's blind I can't even
close out if I tried I can't remember
him what he said I just watched the clip
and I forgot it I've never seen anyone
ever close down their life and I've
never seen one internet meme with that
on it as far as put the bunny back in
the box that is the most quotable Nic
Cage line ever given and it's one of the
lines only Nic Cage could give disagree
Kirkman Bruce Willis this could have
been a Bruce Willis part and he would
have not do that what Marilyn could have
said I could eat a peach for our
disagree I mean you would get it by the
history but you wouldn't get the exact
creepy sexy confusion everybody know and
you're going but it's really this
Harding to hear such a young virile man
like Jon flick just just be so inundated
with memes you can't actually comprehend
what a great movie quote is this more
than three syllables this here Jackie
represents my individuality and my
belief in personal freedom what he is
conveying in that line is a lot of the
same things he's conveying with the
bunny line except this is not a joke
this is actually a mantra that somebody
can use whether it's a senior quote or
whether it's good for the rest of their
life this person look true to who they
are as opposed to a jokey line in an
action movie
they had real meaning behind it but
never rises above a second-rate
yippie-ki-yay MF
and as far as the eat a peach goes it is
only used as a reason to show why he's
that evil and you could have had any
line in there but they're only putting
it in to call it back a lot like a comic
who's going to say a line early in their
scent just like and say it again letter
there so which I've tried a number of
times yes oh wow
that's essential to the plot of the
movie for it to be spoken in such a way
and he nailed it whereas in wild at
heart he actually only said it twice I
just saw this movie again last night
you know that's why I said it's a great
mantra because it in that specific scene
kind of a throwaway fashion where she's
heard a 50,000 times even she's bored of
hearing that life no one gets bored of
hearing either really fine but I would
argue that the lady who is told he
two-piece got pretty bored of that line
or one working she thought she'd suck on
that tongue she looked at martini a
father figure in her life and don't
worry bud that and then he abandoned her
but my favorite lines color is what do
you think is going to do I'm going to
save the [ __ ] day sorry that's all
started that is an iconic bad lion
explosions behind but the funny line is
just he anyone could say that line he
has eye contact and that's great right
what is that well I like the bunny why
because it's different than what you get
a normal action movie but it still never
gets the bug just like it sees the
action movie wanting to eat a peach it's
just another sawaki over-the-top bad
guys my quote from wildin har thing or
even why Lawrence characters having is
having a joke with is because she has
her there's a number of time and this
defines who this man is you clearly see
how they are in love how they are indeed
wild at heart and she acknowledges that
it is because this guy has this belief
in himself it's not actually about the
jacket and II anything about the jacket
it's about his belief in personal
freedom and individuality that's the
goal of that movie and its showcase is
in that line so much better than the
bunny line which is cute but ultimately
forgettable as much as the internet will
try to make you remember it this is an
absolute reaching I'll are the same
thing that you just said the bunny it's
more than just a bunny it's about
freedom it's about going home this is
the last thing that he has to grasp onto
on this plane with these maniacs this is
the freedom this is everything that yes
this is his life this bunny is a man's
life mark the jacket that you're talking
about
the quote honest I keep trying to
remember and I still can't do it I've
never heard anyone be a menace and uh
and and yes I'm not even the best my
reading of the movie it's also it's also
a line that you could put into any movie
you could put that line into any movie
and make it work you could not put my
line in any other because most women
better than kana here know much that's a
lot you know it the second time you're
here and give the line reading he's in a
party sequence there's a metal band
playing and he almost gets in a fight
and he's staring the mountie shakes off
his jacket and he delivers the line
that's emblematic that's a throwaway
performance I think it doesn't the dog
has a great line then you would probably
go to the violin reading of that line
but I prefer to do an expression where
your heart is that at the time versus
I'm gonna kick your ass yeah we can't
get out of our action movie phrases with
these two Andy I'm talking about a man's
entire life here this is his personal
mantra as opposed to something he
thought of when he was on a plane with a
bunch of crazy convicts or something
that an evil guy said just for the sake
of calling it back later in the movie
the character that gave your line in
your film wasn't on the verge of die he
wasn't on a plane with maniacs my guy
was he was about to die every second
along the way he's trying to go home he
just wants to go home put the bunny back
in the box please
so he can go fight Cyrus the virus go
home tie a tie of the yellow ribbon
around the tree the soldier boys coming
home and I'm going to easy to believe
that it's a big line but he doesn't
deliver in a big way he delivers it an
oozing peach dripping obviously Ramsay's
mouth it is a subtle layering of what
Nick Cage could go big on but he doesn't
and that's why so second is this subtle
Menace of it it's disgusting but also
alluring final thoughts going back
around John anything else you'd like to
add for your final thought I would like
to say that my line was given by the
only man who could give that line in
such a way to where you can take it
serious when you're watching the movie
you buy into it no one's laughing at
that line when they're watching the
movie yeah 20 years later they are but
at the time you're watching that movie
you're enthralled you buy into this man
and his anger and this bunny insist it's
a goofy line but he delivers in such a
way that it is believable
Charlie so and I was just saying it is
the line delivery of the century because
he doesn't overplay it he said
in such a committed creepy way that the
woman looks at him knows that this is a
come-on that is so gross note that he is
talking about going down on her like a
peach and is like all right I'm gonna
stop in your town game on
that's how subtle and disgusting and
great and it's all the layers that that
performance has to be for it to slip
around it is not a MacGuffin is an
exciting point wherever is just like oh
yes and it makes you excited as a viewer
okay we get it the piece is about or
collection in padrone's line I think the
question was what is the best one line
or what is the best line reading in
Nicolas Cage's history not what is going
to make the best internet name come on
got you guys are better than this if
we're talking about great comedies I'm
throwing Annie Hall a shoe and you're
putting it back with the movie where a
kid has sex with a pie looks like about
elastic line more so than just something
that fits on a cold picture this jacket
represents my individuality and my
belief in personal freedom
flicka's acting like it's some long
Shakespearean play it is not that tough
to remember it represents everything
about Nicolas Cage as a man as an actor
it has that character in love with laura
dern it works in multiple settings I'll
agree with you which all does not but
the best reading of it is when he's
talking to his sweetheart they're going
to have romantic turmoil throughout the
entire course of their life but because
they understand each other and she likes
when he does that line and she give him
that sly grin it's like this is my man
because I know what he stands for and I
believe in him all right Dan mr. cage
well I will say that there are many
suggestions online from people that
chose their favorite but there was one
that rose to the cream of the crop but
if I could mr. cage read out one for me
please
thank fi I'm going to steal the
Declaration of Independence but that was
the choice of a Twitter fan I thought
about it a on event a lot of them chose
that one other than that a clean round
that would note that the I'm gonna eat a
feature ours thee that I believe that
that a flight attendant was a undercover
cop as well so she was playing one
playing along yes but she did indeed
suck his tongue yes she did
so it's not a deep undercover very deep
covers DVD covers intro we had the the
nice hole is very close very close this
one's rough actually Dan Jimmy thoughts
based on this going down I mean I have
this instinct but I'm just curious for
me I would say i see where alice is
coming from is he from the artistic
standpoint and nicks wearing the jacket
today but for me I I already have a
memory and me it's a treat ya like that
Charlie jacket represents my interval
individualized individuality my move and
I burn it up here my friend I think you
brought acting to a cage fight and I for
me between John and Charlie yeah like
that I agree with here in this
particular round I don't know if that
was the best fit so yeah and Charlie did
point out there is and there is a later
reason is actually potentially better
which is a good job but I did love
John's backup of you that bunny is his
life like he did there's there is
meaning to both of these lines but then
yeah you said Woody Allen could pull off
speech lines so I don't know I think
Bruce Willis could pull off bunny line
and I couldn't hear Willis do I mean
nobody can do Charlie's so based off
those arguments I'm going to give
Charlie too slight that's okay what
yelling happy so creepy addition Woody
Harrelson better maybe I will say the
online poll came down to those two and
the winner by 47 to 43% right now was
Charlie I could beat a piece for hours
there's the funny back of the box
43% right charlie that means you're
making it to the final blind rat blind
blind uh what's a couple beer out these
very long day you can't solve an exam up
for tomorrow's March flick big sucker
and I bought and you mighta good way too
much neck we're doing that again so my
whole day as mental cuz I did why did
way too much my busines you we were like
I was like where is it I hope I really
work you'll see you tomorrow 4 p.m. all
right round 5
comes in from sin tweets Anthony over
there at pins tweets what Nicholas Cage
character would win a cage match a
bare-knuckle fight to the death anyone
you can pick let's start back to Charlie
who are you picking in a bare-knuckle
fight okay it all comes down to who will
fight longer crazier more Nick Cage and
when I think about that character I'm
going back to Bad Lieutenant
because new travelers have it has no
scruples he has got nothing he is on
that crack he sees the edge and he
snorts the edge he does not care about
anyone but himself you would think it's
his girlfriend but he doesn't care about
his girlfriend he cares about what's
going to get him high next we have a
character like that ask anyone in
Florida you do not mess with them
because they will kill you they will put
bathtub all over themselves and rip your
face off and there is no one who can
step into this ring who is going to
match that intensity I don't even when
he's good even pre drug addiction when
he is looking at the guy got to drown
from Katrina he makes fun of the dude
before saving us he is a sociopath
and I wouldn't want to see him after
dark because he might mess me up and I
can't imagine here stepping in the brain
back in Chopin mark first of all Andy he
sees the edge in East Norton is a better
line than anything we argue in the last
round that is phenomenal I'm going to go
with a young man that Nicolas Cage
played that is a big fan of bunnies
Cameron Poe from Cana air this guy has
it all when you talk about a fight he's
got the guts to survive because he's got
something to live for Andy he's got his
wife and his baby girl always just
trying to get back to so he's going to
give maximum effort at all times he's in
much better shape than most other
Nicolas Cage movies Justin C prime of
Nicolas Cage as an action star you've
got the long flowing hair that looks
great but more than aesthetics Andy this
is about intimidation it's about a guy
who knows how to fight he was in the
army
the only reason he was in jail is
because he was defending his wives
against a drunken bar patron he thought
he was going to get
pretty easy because it's manslaughter
you know I went to Sam Quinn for ten
years because they call him a lethal
weapon because he's got military
training holy crap you combined the army
training with ten years in prison nobody
is going to top that medicine the ring
and then you add on the emotional
element that he has something to live
for after this fight he's going to kill
where he's going up against because he's
got a wife and a kid and he she's got to
get their bunny back all right John I'm
going to go with Nick Cage his Big Daddy
and kick ass this is a man who went to
prison for a crime he did not commit and
he wants to come back and serve visions
to those who are wrong he essentially
plays a character a bad man he's a
tactician he's a badass he uses weaponry
he's hand-to-hand combat skills he has a
sidekick named Hit Girl and there's a
scene in the film where he takes up 27
mafia members in a matter of minutes
with his bare hands he blows it up he
takes everyone out there's no one who
could beat Nicolas Cage in this movie he
is a tactician he's badass and I'm gonna
go without ya so I'm gonna go with the
baguette II Christopher mintz-plasse
defeated Big Daddy in Canada McLovin
murdered your hero and as far as Bad
Lieutenant goes Nicolas Cage may even
sleep through the fight this is a fight
of the okay Corral
he ain't showing up he's too coked out
of his mind to be able to focus he's
gonna have some crazy Co strength early
on believe me I've been to Panama City
I've seen crazy coastering but after
that wears off Cameron Poe is going to
be the guy who can think his way through
a fight Andy he's seen drunken bar
patrons he's seen the scariest criminals
on the face of the earth at 30,000 feet
he not only had to fend off bad guys he
had to fend off good guys who were also
on his tail he's taken down everybody in
his life I think one more crappy
lieutenant is going to be an easy W for
mr. Cameron oh you say his strength is
family I say it's his weakness if you
get him in a fight and you're like I've
got your wife and child hop it and I get
hit girl hostage they're out there going
to do whatever you say he has nothing no
one if you don't give a crap about his
girlfriend he just cares about the next
score there's no one who can match the
intensity no one who can match is crazy
and again keeps you down by that why
didn't you put them in a cage all
Cameron Poe or Big Daddy have to do is
die
a bag of coke in front of him and throw
it in a go fresh Thomas fight in your
leg you get this crack crook afterwards
yeah and you say this guy kidnapped your
family he's going to be killed by
Cameron puzzle if the guy simply has too
much skill Andy this is a Conor McGregor
Floyd meta where the situation you're
putting somebody who is ill-equipped to
be in the ring with Cameron Pope because
yes Bad Lieutenant he's going to be
cracked out and fighting out of their
minds that only takes you so far drunken
bastard any game you're cracked out
you're bobbing and weaving and waving
you can't even I wouldn't go down more
crack than you besides that is probably
no Bad Lieutenant his weakness was an
iguana he was easily distract you
couldn't wanted him he's done doubt for
the count I also not going badminton it
he had a limp and back problems he was
on painkillers he was doped out of his
mind he can barely even walk down the
street let alone get in a bare-knuckle
fistfight as far as Cameron Cameron Poe
goes in the movie Conair the only reason
don't wait he's going to get enough
fistfight with anyone as if you provoked
him by by sexually assaulting his wife
like he does in the film without that
he's a cool normal dude he's not gonna
mess with you yeah I agree enough not
only if Terence McDonagh gonna kill you
when you died you gonna shoot your soul
that's how much he's going to kill
you're going to kill your soul for
dancing you can take out you sure like
all the character motivations you want
as to why they are in this arbitrary
fight but once you get in the ring I'm
talking about a fight for survival you
put them in a pit a lot like what
happened to Cameron Poe on that airplane
no he did not want to fight anybody it's
not the desire to fight that is going to
win this battle it's when you get put in
a situation when the odds are stacked
against you who's going to come out on
top
the answer is Cameron Poe because he
took down bad guys he took down good
guys who thought he was the bad guy he's
got military training he's got prison
pounds he's got everything you need plus
one bunny to get back to his wonderful
white job but the other thing is he's a
guy named aggressive character Big Daddy
is a man he's a tactician
he took out more characters in one scene
in my film
then camera coach is an entire movie of
Conair until he got violent and Superman
you can get killed by McLaws you're
completely wrong on that he did not get
close he was tricked into and he was
tricked and then he was bombarded and
then he was tied into a chair and lit
fighting some mental game he was nearly
beat
and lit on fire and he never once gave
up or surrender he's a cute dummy who's
running around in a super Cameron Poe
not only is he a prison guy so he has
that ability too
but as a military trained operative he
also was able to tactically think his
way through a fight which Big Daddy was
his fatal flaw and bam lieutenant said
goodbye the first time you started a lot
in mortuary training but also scruples
he the man who has a coach he's a good
guy he's the protagonist
he's got levels he will not reach to get
the job done unless you have a five
minutes good didn't ya give his wife at
his kids I have a bag of coke go fetch I
win the fight
no but if I have your webcam I'm going
to blow their brains out he's going to
stop the fight well I think Cameron Paul
was going to win the day and save his
kids he does who think oh you got him
like us we're going to have an awkward
Thanksgiving for the rest of our life
he's gonna take life into his own hands
and you're gonna go represent kids I
gotta say just a cup cleanest up the
name if they threw a bag of coke that
really would cancel out lieutenant I
feel like it'd be really hard to rein
him in anyway make another face no II
just go do the coke I think they got so
I gotta say I think it's but I'm just a
colonist so I can really get into the
game because I think Bad Lieutenant it
with all the problems health problems
aside those motivations probably are
going to be the same as Big Daddy and
Cameron Poe if they're if they're being
motivated by their loved ones or
whatever so I'm just final thoughts here
from you two because it's now between
you two how does Cameron Poe take out
Big Daddy how does Big Daddy take out
Cameron Poe Alyssa Cameron Poe has a set
of morals he doesn't want to kill people
Big Daddy will slice you he will kill
you he will do whatever it takes to take
you down he doesn't think twice about it
his skill set is much bigger than
Cameron pose his ham combat skills gun
training he has a cape and a yellow
utility belt Cameron Poe has none of
these things that's right Big Daddy is a
delusional think superhero and that's
going to hurt him when he gets in the
ring against somebody who actually knows
how to handle himself and it's not just
the henchmen Cameron Poe yes he does not
want to kill people but he's proven in
the past if he is provoking in a fight
you are provoked in this scenario he is
being provoked
he knows how to handle it he knows how
to take you down quick hard and do it
cleanly to multiple foes whether they
are the most evil people those rancid
humans on the face of the planet
or they're the good guys who
also have similar tactical training
Cameron Poe is the best of the best from
an army perspective he came out of San
Quentin after 10 long years he has
family motivation to win and succeed in
this fight unlike Big Daddy who is kind
of giving up and passing the torch along
to Hit Girl Cameron Poe almost lost in
the fight against Cyrus the virus an old
man he's delusional there was no threat
there there was no trick daddy was there
by a can whose idea was McLovin but he
still went up against a warehouse of 27
mafia members fully loaded and took
every single one of them out without
hesitation without a problem
Cameron Poe was just trying to survive a
couple prisoners on a plane you ask
anybody who's ever been in a
professional fight a lot of it is
physical but the better part of it is
mental he can outsmart Big Daddy because
Big Daddy got outsmarted by a guy who is
a sexy hamburger cool all right this is
rough Nick Cage what do you think of
course you're all conveniently
forgetting about the Croods
I played a giant caveman I have the
cabling a climb yeah this is a Paris Lee
many ghost riders so this is
bare-knuckle brawl it's a great argument
I say go for the caveman you know he's
he's the patriarch of the Croods he's
the hunter of the family one of his fan
he had up there as caveman strikes I
thought wasn't the bit was going south
but you sold me there at the end yeah
Dan yeah that was Twitter's opinion as
well many many people are very surprised
that nobody took ghostwriter considering
that he is the undead spirit of
vengeance and would have a leg up on any
of the mortals ah good boys will be
forgave in the cab yeah buddy you guys
haven't seen guys on coconut fights in
the way that I've acted in the arena
fact-checking I think that Marc is
overstating like Lovins influence on Big
Daddy's death he was part of the events
but it was also his father was still
around it was his goon so there was it
was a mug loving co-production it was
your children was it just Michael Lovell
where are you going based on me on these
arguments ooh
I agree that bad lieutenant's got way
too much going on
way too much going on I had to be honest
I was leaning toward Cameron Poe but
take that it's a toss-up for me I think
John closed very strong
I think Ellis kind of was dominating in
the ls was not me and John did come back
and it's exactly my notes as well cool
but then mark did have the delay he was
a dilutional superhero if camera pose
provoked that's why I get hung up on the
end I feel like Big Daddy was beaten
Cameron Poe was not so based on that is
the slight edge I got to give it to mark
but that was a fans aren't sure Hardy
around the page we're damned you know
good arguments from both you got from
all three of you really but mark did
throw out the eye if you throw my cake
okay badly Senate which was I learned a
point for you you're a divergent item
Bravo market Charlie all right dose of
John you're still omission help and
probably what I'm what a good sight I
think would win in a point in real life
and that's done with you are you guys
going sweetheart tell me your judgment
that's true okay here we go
Oh God speed round you know how this
works let's do it for national treasure
3 what relic land marker item should
cage steal next
arkad a coveted bed the Statue of
Liberty
all right charlie so they should seal
the Ark of the Covenant because you've
got the added pressure of it opening and
then taking all your faces I want to see
them go on this wild adventure and
they've got to find where any other
Jones has left it that we would actually
be a crossover event between national
treasure and IANA Jones and who doesn't
want to see Harrison Ford versus Nicolas
Cage alright I think it would just feel
like reaching you're trying to go back
to Raiders of the Lost Ark you can't
make a better movie than Raiders of the
Lost Ark but the first movie where you
steal the Statue of Liberty you're just
upping the stakes to an incredible
degree a lot like when David Copperfield
made a distance here you're
incorporating bad
elements in here but Nicolas Cage and
his team of rogue bandits can do it they
can outsmart the bad guys just in time
to make the Statue of Liberty disappear
and reappear earlier Copperfield's
already did it was already a television
event I want to see that as an
interrupter speed run time it's already
happened it's already been on TV I've
seen it I want to see something new I
don't think you need to replace Raiders
of the Lost Ark but you can talk about
it and bring him into the new soul
achtung Harrisonburg Nic Cage race of
the Lost Ark is one of the great movies
of all time and this one looks like a
immensely a measured copycat as opposed
to stealing the Statue of Liberty which
is also ridiculous but it's ridiculous
in a fun new way as opposed to Whaley
hand right all right I heard enough
there John what do you think baseman's
argument you know as far Statue of
Liberty goes the Ghostbusters stoled
already as well impart to you but and we
asked on the arguments I did have Cena
done multiple times I mean it's we have
well I in other movies so nothing really
original but you know what as far as the
argument goes I don't buy into it I
don't see it happening the Statue of
Liberty being stolen anytime soon I'm
gonna go with your argument I could buy
a cardiac entirely alright Nic Cage what
do you think I mean I do already own the
Ark of the coming body is urine again
yeah I'm gonna have to go with the
Statue of Liberty in this one but you do
you do think he would have a way to
steal that oh yeah he would he would
incorporate the help of France this was
originally a gift another taken aback
you hear that line delivery I can see
that on the trip Sam makes an argument
based on the arguments it's much tougher
is it based on the answer is that the
idea of the Statue of Liberty is great
but basing it on the arguments I have to
try this tip for that thank you for the
kind of help we got nominated Josie
hurts it for me yeah the same one you're
going for what's stupider no Eric said
you and I'm fun and I think that's
really a great idea Jupiter that goes
such as didn't steal the statue far away
they swirled it how they don't learn
no one remembers a David Copperfield
thing I think it's more line with the
national treasure brand such I'm going
to go the statute yeah I got to go
statue Liberty - alright markets the
first point here we go not including the
man himself who should play Nicolas Cage
in a biopic Christian Bale hmm mai-chan
good - g'day I don't want to see both of
those movies right now
Shannon versus Bale all right mark your
first Christian Bale is an Academy
award-winning actor who has like Michael
Shannon played biographical roles before
but Christian Bale brings to it is an
ability to physically transform himself
like movies in the machinist or he got
really big for a movie like Batman where
we haven't seen that ability for Michael
Shannon yet he's kind of the same
character in every movie Christian Bale
can be a chameleon depending on what the
role requires Charlie I think Michael
Shannon has in the eyes the crazy
necessary to be Nic Cage I want to see
him with his Presley moment where he has
lost all those money he's marrying the
Ellis's daughter and he doesn't know
where his ass is from his elbow I want
to see him go full out and be Michael
Shannon - an aunt agree in a way that
Nic Cage will only bring out of him and
to see that movie you would get a
definite code you would be able to
otherwise
tenzin I feel like Michael Shannon was
great as Elvis and but you were trying
to capture Nicolas Cage I think it would
be through the vein of Elvis it would be
a caricature where it's Christian Bale
would actually get into the man Nicolas
Cage and not just play this over the top
of them okay just somebody's obsessive
Elvis so that's just one quality on top
of it Michael Shannon could portray all
of that it'd be assassinate for trail of
someone who has lost his way but it's so
talented and you could see it play on
his face in a way that you won't be
Christian Bale who Nick Cage let's go to
you first
it's an argument I mean maybe Michael
Shannon could play tiny Elvis but force
it can't play me there's only nobody can
play music what I'm trying to say you're
not come really the most or having one
of a kind
no all right Dan
it's all the I's I think that that
landed with me is that's true so I think
so much of Nicolas Cage's in the eyes
and I think they both make good
arguments for why they're actors good so
that unhinged quality that's what I
think I would say with Charlie that's
kind of quickly on her John yeah it was
a tough one I could actually see
Christian Bale in the role but I your
reasons for why it is especially with
the eyes like Dan said I'm gonna go with
Michael Shannon yeah I sold me to
Charlie you get the point or even again
that Elvis line that was good what
Nicholas Cage film which has never had
one most deserves a sequel The Rock I'll
go wow that's tough faceoff she went
there to ability faceoff and the rock
here we go Alice your first the rock of
the franchisable action-adventure and I
can't believe they haven't made a sequel
to it already because you could have
family Goodspeed who now is a little bit
more wise in the ways of Wetworks he can
go into other very scary high target
areas where terrorists have taken over
because there's terrorism all over the
world you can update it for the times we
live in
he and somebody maybe bring Sean Connery
back or another older veteran can break
into North Korea for example you can
modernize it for the time the rocket
Alcatraz they've already done if they've
already been there whereas with face-off
we have technology that are so new now
we can have this complete new other
cyber portion of it we've got Nick Cage
and John Travolta reprising but then
we've got a third fate another three
phases running around if you don't know
who is who and you can only go by their
acting portrayals because they have to
have such deep characters that you'd be
like oh that John Travolta playing Sam
Rockwell it would be a great Saturday
morning cartoon however Nicolas Cage's
character died in faceoff and he
survived the rock so I think that's a
one up as far as making a sequel with
Nicolas Cage primarily involved at the
action here that heat can be seen action
every single die all the time and come
back to life that's not an argument
I want to see three faces up faces up
twenty years is the right time to bring
this back around it is the moment for
face off - Wow all right I kind of want
to see them both there's a reason I love
the I would break into North Korea and I
did love the third adding the third face
and every time in North Korea would be
young I was there so I'm torn it gonna
need first Shan what do you think I want
to see built as well as far I really do
and I want to talk about it like three
hours thing is you had a good point he
dies and face off it's very hard but
with your with your concept you can go
into modern-day terrorism and make sense
then the cage team up with somebody else
besides Sean Connery again I could see
those things happening and I think it
lends itself to a better sequel so I'm
gonna go mark yeah mentor what's
realistic him be coming back to life or
getting Sean Connery that's my thing I
don't think you get shot I'll get Sean
kind of hired and you peer out there
just sir I could have anyone though I
like the processor that's kind of all I
needed to hear it so I'm going with
face-off cause I know sir so with Mark
until the third is not a pleasure out of
those you were running and you found it
and make it very guy space drop they
could bring it back from the dead that's
what I said yeah you can bring them back
to life they've kept them on ice because
Sam Rockwell wants to get on it whatever
it is all right we were boys Kuwait both
I wish I could both give you points but
I can't Charlie will get that boy a
triple faceoff three-card Monte there
you go here we go next up um oh oh oh
boy though that is that fair
no no good go for it yeah it's fair
it'll be fun yeah did I do a line of
coke and then to a Nicolas Cage I think
it's fair here we go I'm gonna name two
films tell me what's better let's do it
the rock versus face-off Oh
right thankful reward I think oh yeah
let's hear this out all right Rock
person's face off your first mark the
rock is the greatest action movie of the
90s because you take an all-time acting
legend like Sean Connery you pair him
with a rising star like Nicolas Cage you
have a up-and-coming at the time
director before he got transformers
Michael Bay it's a great combination of
neat premise where you actually have to
break into Alcatraz there's so many
movies we have to break down in prison
you've never had to break into prison
before an ED Harris's bad guy lends a
gravitas to the roles you do not get in
a cartoon-like play some people remember
that space bomb is actually a sci-fi
movie so the sci-fi action movie and
asserted by John Ruth you've got these
operatic beautiful pigeons slider or
done flying through the air you've got
these battles between guns and the space
down between John Travolta and Nick Cage
and they're both in their element
they're hamming it up they're also
restraining themselves to be the
protagonist it is fun it is engaging is
something that people remember forever
the flaws in space offer a lot more
apparent whether it's the obvious use of
stuntmen or it's Nicolas Cage and John
Travolta clearly masking the fact that
as well doing impressions of each other
or it's John Lewis stealing a lot of his
better stuff from his previous movies
Michael Bay was furthering his national
emergency has come and gone they thought
people are actually celebrating oh sorry
I might still argue anymore
yes markets more time oh no wait I
didn't do nothing we do it Charlie had a
revolver gun I was like I was around
Omar turn it over so I'll get them to
sorry finish your rebuttal okay so the
rock has already had an anniversary come
and gone the faith office 20 years and
we remember it people remember face off
because it's an interesting concept that
has never been done before the rock has
been done before you've seen these sorts
of action sequences but you've never
seen a face up ever great much did you
get enough I did okay did you get enough
yeah I feel like all right John go uh oh
that's a tough one you guys both made a
good point I think mark made more points
against your movie so for that I'm gonna
go work on that one damn that's what won
me over to mark brought up something
that I didn't even remember that it's
one of the very few things that I
actually don't like against about
faceoff which is the obvious use of
stuntmen he's right that prisoner suck
so bad is based on I
have to side with mark based on the
negative points that he brought up
against
based on Nick why do you use a stuntman
I'm with you that puts us in a tie Nick
yeah whatever I don't want to ruin my
beautiful things although both films
have great quotes we have the rock with
a how will the name of Zeus's what hole
did you get out of yourself and we have
faced off with I could take my face off
for hours I'm gonna have to go a fake
off because it's just a lot of stupid
fun and that's what that's what I enjoy
in my own movies is just stupid fun well
I'm going to give mark a point but
Charlie the measurement cage himself
takes face-off so they're your Co but
mark we're now tied last quarter you
guys all right here we go I'm going to
go crazy here if you could recast any
Star Wars role with Nicolas Cage what
would be the most effective swap the
Emperor uh okay on my god Saigon
I can see wow I was a George IV all
right we got camper up versus Jarobi
yeah if you recall before you just
became the Emperor Senator Palpatine was
a very cunning trickster in politics and
Nicolas Cage can pull off that charming
guy but also there's something there's
death behind those eyes and what's going
to be working as a sip board when he
gets into the role of the Emperor that's
funding a little over the top with the
Blue Lightning you can see the eyes that
we always talk about the Nicolas Cage
going crazy with the Blue Lightning
teaching and apprentice going against
the good guys that's what Nicholas Cage
can do this but there's a great shiny
arrow that says this is an evil
character that is going to come and kill
everybody I want to see him be a
restrained Joe dead character I want to
see him take someone by the hand and
teach him the Jedi way I think he has it
in him I want to see the long hair I
feel like he's got the kicks we've seen
him do jumping kicks
he's got the the athleticism and I also
feel like he has the soul and spirit of
a Jedi unfortunate everybody can rewind
back to when you shoot on the Sorcerer's
Apprentice so bad because he was trying
to play a good whiz
there seems to be a bad wizard and
unlike qui-gon the Emperor survives
multiple movies and lives on after death
we haven't seen qui gonn since family
Charlie get some extra time we don't
seem but once the only need once the
only one time to see him really act this
out do the role be an action star and do
the sort of samurai movie that George
Lucas wanted to see and he has that it
and he has that nobility and that
knighthood and you want to see him fight
death not that was it everything on time
thing yes that's torn is it because he
picked the Emperor he didn't pick
Palpatine well does that matter because
they were different people
no no and then Empire what I'm not one
of the main it stays the same actors
name actor yet even transformed into
Emperor Palpatine but you are you
picking something which because in
Empire I'm sorry I refer as Emperor
Palpatine but if you want to do well you
got it you're big you met Palpatine yes
you're going in higher I got it because
the Emperor is more I think Empire which
was various a McDormand it was who was
who was the original MB McDermott he
played the original Jedi yeah yeah yeah
I ran to that part of you just a random
person Empire Strikes Back that's one
thing you know buddy up every second I
live every brought it in with us alright
so that's fair okay let me gather my
thoughts and John oddly enough I could
see Nic Cage playing a good guy Jedi in
the Star Wars films for some odd reason
but Marx points is reasons for being the
Emperor I could see him starting out as
you don't quite know if he's a dubious
character or not then he turns into a
complete jerk wad I'm gonna go with I'm
gonna go with mark on that one Nic Cage
I like I like the idea of that Emperor
port of call New Orleans I'm gonna have
to go with that one damn the way that
they set up their arguments was that I
have to choose between restrained Nick
Cage and crazy Nick Cage
and I think the one that I would rather
see is crazy the cage so I got to go
with the approval look it's up to me he
does have the soul and spirit of a Jedi
that was a good line and I do agree I
mean I think he could totally play that
role but I really want to see him with
the Blue Lightning yes the emerging your
nails yes so that was so close Charlie
gonna give the window the mark Alyn
unlimited powers the damn thing oh wow
get out I got any more coming next time
man are you guys for coming Mark Ellis
I'm Mark Ellis live on Twitter and we
got to thank you and schmoes know you're
trying to get them over the 300
subscriber this will you guys go there
subscribe on your show they know on
YouTube and subscribe and then go over
and the flip pick it subscribe there
let's look at John a nice big boost as
well at John Flickinger on Twitter and
movie versus Google Plus use a lot of
places to find you but yeah anything
else you want to sort of call out I know
yeah definitely look out for movie
versus movie it's a fun time we're
shooting season number two lots of
popcorn I love doing it so check it out
it's super fun and I love your flick
trips and all that stuff on your channel
as well so go support there charlie
Feldman Charlie felt when people can see
you at SJ news where else would you like
to send them my Twitter is pretty pretty
fun Carolee underscore Belvin come join
ray we have a time sometimes Bravo all
three jane muhrlin merle dan thank you
for coming and Nicolas Cage Bravo I hear
your Twitter is at Brock Baker yes weird
we related but yes that is my Twitter
and lots of bees it's not not to be in
that Brock Baker to find mr. Nicolas
Cage if you'd like to tweeted him it's
just a cool name completing a great crew
you can see the crew on Netflix I think
so or maybe some Lou he flicks alright
and please do it into flick bait every
Friday at 4 p.m. we'll see you there
thank you all of you for coming what a
wonderful fight please tune in to flick
bait Fridays at 4:00 p.m. thank you for
watching have a wonderful day we'll see
you next week for the fewer choice
championship fights bye bye it's late
[Music]
and the plastic gotcha laughing you're
mine good call baby doll okay let's run